the study by Liverpool University and
Imperial College London looked at
sixteen thousand seven hundred and forty
nine people admitted to hospital in the
UK some of these patients are still
being treated for covert nineteen but of
those with outcomes sixty percent were
discharged and sadly forty percent died
Bing male older and having some existing
medical conditions increases a patient's
risk of dying and just over half of the
Cova 19 patients studied here had a
pre-existing condition those with
dementia had the greatest increased risk
of death
39% above average but obesity is also a
key indicator with the chances of dying
increasing by 37 percent although the
range around that number is still quite
wide and clinicians say this link
between obesity and the risk of death
from kovat 19 is no coincidence excess
body fat seems to drive not just
underlying health conditions that coded
19 seems to exploit but excess body fat
also increases chronic inflammation in
the body so mild chronic damage to the
body over a number of years and what
happens with poket 19 is that people
that tragically die from it died because
of an exaggerated immune response that
attacks the lung something called a RDS
or acute respiratory distress syndrome
which ultimately causes death in a
tragic minority of people so let's look
at how the levels of obesity in the UK
compared to other countries around the
world many of which have been hit hard
by kovat 19 the number of covered 19
deaths in the UK is among the highest in
Europe and more than a quarter of adults
some 28% are classed as obese in the
u.s. that figure is more than a third at
36% but in countries with a lower number
of deaths like South Korea in Japan less
than five percent of adults are obese
one thing that is concerning scientists
and researchers is the number of people
from certain ethnic groups dying would
cove at 19 we don't know why
for certain but it could be linked to a
number of factors including obesity a
recent active life survey published by
the Office for National Statistics found
72 percent of the black African and
Caribbean community in the UK are
overweight or obese the highest
proportion of any ethnic group we are
learning more about this Nivelle virus
every day how and who it attacks and the
more information we have about those
most at risk more lives we'll be able to
save